[Music]
what makes a good horror story sure you
could throw in some hideous monsters
fountains of blood and things jumping
out from every corner but as classic or
author
HP Lovecraft wrote the oldest and
strongest kind of fear is fear of the
unknown and writers harness that fear
not by revealing Horrors but by leaving
the audience hanging in anticipation of
them that is in a state of suspense the
most familiar examples of suspense who
come from horror films and mystery
novels what's inside the Haunted Mansion
which of the dinner guests is the
murderer but suspense exists beyond
these genres will the hero save the day
will the couple get together in the end
and what is the dark secret that causes
the main character so much pain the key
to suspense is that it sets up a
question or several that the audience
hopes to get an answer to and delays
that answer while maintaining their
interest and keeping them guessing so
what are some techniques you can use to
achieve this in your own writing limit
the point of view instead of an
omniscient narrator who can see and
relay everything that happens tell the
story from the perspective of the
characters they may start off knowing
just as little as the audience does and
as they learn or so do we classic novels
like Dracula for example are told
through letters and diary entries where
characters relate what they've
experienced and fear what's to come next
choose the right setting and imagery old
mansions or castles with winding halls
and secret passageways suggest that
disturbing things are being conceived
nighttime fog and storms all play
similar roles
visibility and restricting characters
movements
that's why Victorian London is such a
popular setting and even ordinary places
and objects can be made sinister as in
the gothic novel Rebecca where the
flowers at the protagonists new home are
described as blood-red three play with
style and form you can build suspense by
carefully paying attention not just to
what happens but how it's conveyed and
paced Edgar Allan Poe conveys the mental
state of the narrator in the tell-tale
heart with fragmented sentences that
break off suddenly and other short
declarative sentences in the story
create a mix of breathless speed and
weighty pauses on the screen Alfred
Hitchcock's cinematography is known for
its use of extended silences and shots
of staircases to create a feeling of
discomfort for use dramatic irony you
can't just keep the audience in the dark
forever
sometimes suspense is best served by
revealing key parts of the big secret to
the audience but not to the characters
this is a technique known as dramatic
irony where the mystery becomes not what
will happen but when and how the
characters we learn in the classic play
Oedipus Rex the title character is
unaware that he has killed his own
father and married his mother but the
audience knows and watching Oedipus
gradually learned the truth provides the
story with its agonizing climax and
finally the cliffhanger beware of
overusing this one some consider it a
cheap and easy to
but it's hard to deny its effectiveness
this is where a chapter episode volume
or season cuts off right before
something crucial is revealed or in the
midst of a dangerous situation with a
slim chance of hope the wait weather
moments for years makes us imagine
possibilities about what could happen
next building extra suspense the awful
thing is almost always averted creating
a sense of closure and emotional release
but that doesn't stop us from worrying
and wondering the next time the
protagonists facing near certain
disaster ted-ed
is a non-profit if you value our work
please consider supporting it on
patreon.com slash ted-ed
[Music]